somebody will get upset that I've said
this but the truly the whole thing is is
steeped in like psychoanalyzing people
you disagree with in paranoia and it's
all about systems of power and the way
that those influence everything so that
nothing can be authentic and it's all
kind of whining and complaining and very
pessimistic very cynical it has that
characteristic where you've probably run
into this where you know it's wrong and
it's not hard to see how it's wrong it's
easy to see how it's persuasive though
and it's going to take you a lot of work
to explain why it's wrong in a
satisfactory way and it's really a
negative place to be I don't think it's
fun to do this at all are you the sort
of the guy that's had to walk over hot
coals to try and retrieve something of
value from the other side a little bit
so if it's you that's that's suffering
this this discomfort that is a good way
to put it yeah in a sense that's I feel
like that's kind of what I'm doing now
is I really want to understand the
mindset and understand it in a way
that's faithful to what it actually is
that portrays it accurately but also in
a way that I can communicate that back
to other people in plain language so
that they can see it for what it is
without having to go read tons of it and
it is like walking back and forth back
and forth across the coals knowing every
single time that it's it's gonna be hot
again so I mean the listeners you will
have joined us there's usually an intro
but me and James had too much to talk
about so welcome back I'm joined by
James Lindsay and we are talking about
an awful lot of different interesting
things today principally critical theory
that's principally what I've been
thinking about yeah what is what is
critical theory I don't know what
critical theory is critical theory is a
way to view the world the long and short
of it is that it's a way to view the
world that sees the world in terms
of sub then there are multiple critical
theories there are many critical
theories it at its very bottom it's a
way to view the world where everything
relevant in terms of at least of social
relations has to do with power dynamics
that are in society between some group
with power and other groups who don't
have as much power and the object of
critical theory is to say that the
groups that have power carry certain
assumptions and biases and the likes and
they bake that into the systems that
they create without realizing that
they're doing it so the critical
theorists job is to expose those biases
and uncover those assumptions so that
they can be critiqued
and re-examined and usually discarded
dismantled subverted or otherwise
overthrown so you would have this in the
marxist sense the power group would
either be the capitalists or the
bourgeoisie which be a property holding
class and they you know in a kind of a
very direct sense control the working
class and kind of control how they're
supposed to think and set the fashion
and set the tone of what high society is
supposed to look like or how the
businesses are supposed to be operated
and they exploit the working class which
would be the oppressed group critical
theory grew out of that mindset in what
the Institute for Social Research that
was set up in front for Germany in the
20s that it's now called the front firt
school and they actually following off
of the Italian Communist Floss for
Antonio Graham she realized that you
know Marx predicted there would be this
revolution the proletariat would rise up
and overthrow the capitalists and the
bourgeoisie and this didn't happen and
they wanted to know why so Antonio
Gramsci came up with this idea
that's called cultural hegemony and
that's the idea that the powerful
classes of society set the way that
everybody's supposed to think and
everybody else buys in
that so they won't go against it and
then the Frankfurt School kind of ran
with this idea and started saying that
things like liberalism and Western
civilization themselves bacon the
assumptions of their creators and make
it so that the people who have power
which would mostly be white Western men
who are straight and so on
have both explicitly and inadvertently
cooked up systems of power so that they
benefit themselves and exclude those
that they don't want to take to have the
power because it powers a zero-sum
object in this worldview so critical
theory is in that sense a way of looking
at the world that sees the world that
way and that essentially tries to pick
at whatever the system is so as to tear
apart the hidden assumptions and biases
that's the most charitable way to put it
it's what they say that they're doing is
tearing apart the hidden assumptions and
biases to make the system more fair or
as they phrased it in the Frankfurt
School to make it into an ideal
democracy where nobody is actually has
their voice or their opportunity or
whatever shortchanged so that's a very
long definition but it fakes value that
sounds critical theory sounds pretty
good it it's definitely something that
when used appropriately a critical
method at least can be very very useful
and in fact the Enlightenment tradition
which has brought us you know pretty
much all of modernity like the ability
to Skype and have a good microphones and
things the Enlightenment tradition could
very easily be seen as an appropriate
use of critical methods it started to
question the authority of say the church
and it started to say let's defer to an
external authority the essentially the
the way nature works to answer our
questions about the world and let's try
to appeal to reason and logic and
[Music]
evidence as much as we can in making our
decisions and so it started to create
this very different way to see the world
that presented a very useful skepticism
against the previous kind of
mythological and episcopate type and
monarchical type mindsets where you had
these literally powerful individuals who
then decide I did you know either
repetition of Scripture or the
organization of society or whatever and
whatever their fancy was was how it went
you know the the law was what the King
said the law was or you know the
scripture is at the Pope interpret
interprets it to say and so on so yes
the issue is that a critical theory
there that so this is philosopher Max
Horkheimer in the front for school laid
out the difference between what's
technically called a critical theory and
what he called a traditional theory both
of which exist but in a broader kind of
critical thinking tradition that we
would think of and the point of a
traditional theory is to understand a
thing it's just to understand it the
point of a critical theory is to
understand how it goes wrong and in
particular how it goes wrong according
to some normative vision which means a
moral structure and how to qualify as a
critical theory it must be explanatory
about how it is particularly an unjust
thing so it's looking for in justices in
the system and nothing else no attempt
to understand how the thing works
necessarily or why those in justices
happen to be what they are or something
like this and it must fit the vision of
the social engineers who are have
decided what justice looks like when
they look for these in justices and it
must be applicable by activists and so
it is in a sense a way of putting the
cart ahead of the horse where you know
are our best knowledge should lead our
decision-making rather
and what we want to be true leading our
approach to figuring out knowledge yeah
so yes the best way that I can think of
it is to actually because I don't want
to say the critical theory is useless
because it's not it's odd that it gets
applied to so much given that it's
mostly a literary thing but I try to say
that it's like a really strong
industrial solvent it has applications
it has uses but man you're not gonna
spread it everywhere you're not going to
give it to kids you're not gonna just
you know dump it on everything you see
it's one of those things that it
certainly has beneficial and appropriate
uses we should be looking for those
biases and those unconsidered
assumptions but we should also do so
responsibly not with an effort only to
pick at how something goes wrong you
must also understand why the system your
situation is the way that it is yeah I
mean that to me is one of the most
enjoyable parts of life for me as
someone who enjoys sense-making
you know I do this podcast and I try and
I try and uncover why things are the way
they are that the tagline to modern
wisdom is understand yourself in the
world around you like yeah yeah I like
doing it it's cool there's nothing
there's no better satisfaction for me
than joining together to different
points with something and you been like
[ __ ] that's why that's why that's that
thing yeah inherently enjoyable but yeah
when it's got this it's the it's the
same central core but it's just facing
in the complete different direction and
this direction this direction is like
you say is trying to work out who has
the power why why is that the case so
how do we because this is something that
I you are I think probably let me give
you let me give you an example real
quick before we go into that so it's
really clear what the difference between
a critical mindset in another you know
I'm you mean as a normal mindset is
although that would be torn apart by
critical
so imagine like I just want to use an
example of say it like an airplane in
the seats on the airplane everybody has
a bad time where the seats on airplanes
except very small women I think so the
seats on airplanes tend to be narrow
they tend to be smaller your knees are
getting banged up against the person in
front of you so on and so forth nobody
is really happy about this now a
traditional theory would try to you know
you have the people who designed the
aircraft and they they had to make
decisions as to how they're gonna
arrange the seats obviously they want to
put as many seats in the plane as they
can given the size of the aircraft and
its weight specifications and so on
because that optimizes for the number of
people who can travel and the amount of
money that they can make with the plane
so those considerations would all fall
under traditional theory a critical
theory would say well these seats are
really uncomfortable and so if we were
to take a lens for example that looks
from what's now called fat studies it
would say and obviously you know
everybody knows that the issue of really
overweight people on airplanes because
the seats are what they are and it makes
the next person over uncomfortable and
sometimes any two seats and you know all
the different things and so the critical
perspective there would say well the
plane was designed by people who are
generally thin or of average size not
overweight and so they have a blind spot
to what it's like to be an overweight
person and that is them exercising a
power called thin normativity that sees
thinness as normal and over whiteness as
abnormal and therefore there is a power
relation here between average size or
thin people and they are exerting it on
the oppressed overweight people who are
forced to be uncomfortable on aircraft
because they the people designing the
airplane don't care that ultimately is
what it is that they don't care or they
want fat people not to exist or they
want fat people who lose weight or
whatever happens to be so that's the
difference between the way a critical
mindset the critical mindset is merely
going to look at the size of the chairs
and start complaining the traditional
mindset or a
what Horkheimer called a traditional
theory would say why were the plain
seats designed like this in the first
place and what were the reasons that
went into that why was this considered
to be the best possible decision over
maybe a few iterations of well they used
to be more narrow or they used to be
wider and we figured out we could get
more people and there's there's the one
that tries to understand why the seats
are the way they are and then there's
the one that says this sucks that I want
to complain about it so they're
conformed or not whether they there's
any attention given to the real reasons
that things are the way they are so
that's kind of the difference between a
critical mindset versus a more
comprehensive way to look at things it's
a solvent it's an it tears apart what's
there without necessarily even knowing
what it is
yeah I understand so that's that's
actually I wanted to ask the question
why did social justice come from and can
you give us the academic underpinnings
of it which it sounds like you're really
delving into and I think as well for a
lot of the listeners I've had Douglas
Murray on Andrew Doyle's been on
constant and kissing's coming on soon
and blah blah blah
great so you got all of these people who
are talking about the manifestations of
that but what we're talking about here
and what's my my particular selfish love
of things why is this the way it is so I
want to get into that but the the what
you've come across there to me I think
is quite archetypal in terms of what
appears to be happening overall with
social justice at the moment and this is
that there is a normal distribution of
something anything whether it be gender
expression whether it be performance aid
school based on race or particular job
choices based on in relation to gender
or whatever it might be there is a
particular normal distribution and it
seems to me that one of the hallmarks of
social justice at the moment in its
malignant form because I you know social
justice in its purest form I don't know
30 years ago 40 years ago before this
term sort of began to get hijacked is
actually a really really really good
thing but yeah in its current form it
appears to be there are some people who
have an extreme experience of the world
we need to accommodate them ahead of the
bulk of people that fall within the
normal distribution am i am i a million
miles away there or is that is that is
that what's happening a lot you're
pretty close to the bullseye there's a
number of interesting things that can be
said about that if you want but you are
very close to the inaccurate an accurate
description of what's going on one of
the things that can be said about that
is that what you are so another kind of
useful example here is what's known as
the social model of disability so within
disability studies which has also become
one of these kind of social justice
bastions to the dismay of lots of
disabled people you reach out to me all
the time and say it's wrecking their
lives there's this model that came about
I think in the 80s it may been a little
earlier and it was okay at the beginning
disability studies is really an
interesting case because it's one where
it's really easy to see the point being
made that's good and then how it falls
off the rails the social model of
disability basically said okay so some
people are disabled and it's important
not just to kind of say suck it up
buttercup and figure it out but rather
society should make reasonable
accommodations for disabled people so
there should be you know the the thing
on the sidewalk the ridged area for the
blind people and the traffic signals
should make noise and Rajib's outside of
ramps and in elevators and things yes to
the degree that bathrooms and so on and
so the social model of disability is
exactly what you're just saying there
these people who fall outside of the
normal range of human experience and
there is some expectation that a society
that's well-off enough is doing the
right thing by making them have more
accessibility to that Society so there's
the so it shouldn't all be on the
disabled person to deal with the world
if the society is I mean they usually
don't say it's so explicitly but the
reality is if the society's well-off
enough to be able to afford it there is
a there is a reason to believe that we
have a social obligation to
make things more accessible yes to pay
for those ramps to pay for that to pay
taxes that pay for the thing on the
sidewalk and at the light that the the
crossing light makes noises and things
like that so this seems perfectly
reasonable because it is perfectly
reasonable and then when it starts
becoming as you were distinguishing
between this so that's that is social
justice that is making in the liberal
sense society more just for people on
the outside end of the spectrum at very
some but very little cost to people in
the middle but then where it starts to
become the malignant form is when you
start getting into ideas like and these
are these are valid these are things
that are actually happening that
deafness for example is an identity so
you are a deaf person not a person who
happens to be deaf and so when there's
medical advances and say hearing aid
technology that can give deaf people the
ability to hear that can be
reinterpreted as a medicalization of
deafness or a desire for deafness not to
exist which then can be further
interpreted into a will to genocide
against deaf people so the wish that
that no one would be deaf
because being deaf is a disability is
interpreted when you go too far down
this rabbit hole as wishing there were
no deaf people in the other meaning of
the term as in like they were all their
deafness was all it's so hard to say it
but they literally equated to a genocide
is this not the same it would this not
be the same as when was that when did
the polio jab come out is about a
hundred years ago is that right yeah
yeah yeah it would be the same as 100
years ago to pull your jab being
released and everyone saying right so
you're saying that all of these people
that have got polio to her like walking
around on crutches you're saying you're
saying that they shouldn't exist me like
well I mean by most people's measures of
welfare they would be having a fuller
human experience if they weren't like
that and given the choice between the
two the majority of people if they were
laid out in front of them would also
choose sort of full normal human
function wire is the problem here but as
it's an attack on it's an attack on the
identity or at least that's what it's so
that's the thing it becomes an attack on
the identity which then it gets further
translated into an attack on the people
who carry that identity and you can
start to see how this isn't really a
good way to think about things and then
people start to we will get up to the
listeners we will get on to the academic
underpinnings of social justice in a
second I promise this is cool and
interesting you can increasingly slice
this I am out on the fringes thing right
is that what's happening whereby people
are in making something which isn't
perhaps that much of a disadvantage more
of a exaggerating that so for instance
yeah I think so for instance Douglas I
don't know whether you ever heard the
interview that I did with him but I
asked him what chapters would you have
put in the book in the madness of crowds
that you didn't and he said that one of
them was mental health because he's said
it as far as he was concerned there are
real people who have real problems with
mental health but waving your hand in
the air and saying I have mental health
problems like it's some sort of some
calling card some sort of marker of
distinguishment or whatever it might be
some sort of sympathy card and the other
one was green so those were the two
those are the two that he was he was
considering adding in but yeah I'm
wondering how that you have some people
who have genuinely are out on that the
tail ends of that distribution of normal
yes and who requires social justice to
allow them to be a part of society
because we have to accommodate for them
because that's the good thing to do
within a good society but then there are
people who want accommodations made for
them because why because they want some
attention it's really difficult to say
why but somehow along the way this all
became very identity focused they call
it an identity first mindset and in
other words it adopted identity politics
this maybe is attributable to the black
feminists and that black feminism is a
a type of feminism it I'm not saying
feminists who happen to be black it
turns out black feminism is kind of grew
out of like a the combination of the
Black Power movement and and feminists
feminism I think and it had that those
at any rate and so they very much so
kimberlé crenshaw bell hooks in the
1980s two very famous names among among
people who are paying attention to any
of this now they both were very adamant
that black identity should be first it
should be I am a black person or I am a
black woman rather than I am a person
who happens to be black so in the
kimberlé crenshaw at least was explicit
about it the purpose is so we can do
identity politics what you means so I do
so we can do identity politics what's
that mean it's so the the goal was to
put identity first so that you can use
that matter of identity as a lever to
achieve political ends and it was
explicitly written and for example
Crenshaw's mapping the margins that
identity politics was the goal so there
was this switch sometime in the 80s and
90s to the mainstream even academic
thought becoming very identity politics
oriented and so that started causing
this identity centric kind of thinking
that that you're kind of hinting at or
asking about one other thing to say
about the normal distribution by the way
it's worth mentioning but we won't go
down the rabbit hole is that there's a
trick being played here that everybody
should be aware of which is that the
word normal means two things at once
there's normal in the sense of you know
near the middle of the normal
distribution and then common every day
the regular the expected thing you know
what typical yeah and then there's
there's normal in the sense of normative
which means that it has some moral
valence it's the good thing and so what
they're doing is they're mixing those
two meanings at the same time so they
are actually waging a war against the
normal because they feel like they're
when you expect if lots of people are in
are normal and then you have some
abnormal people the belief is that
there's an automatic you can't have a
neutral understanding of normal and
abnormal there's always normal good
abnormal bad and so they're mixing the
moral with the just descriptive
understandings of those two terms and
they play on that double meaning very
intentionally and more or less
constantly so when you talked about the
normal distribution and then there's the
people on the ends who would be abnormal
that's certainly what's going on and if
you want to know that we can Segway
toward the academic routes thereby
saying that that actually comes from the
understanding of power knowledge and
language that would have come from the
French post modernists specifically
Michel Foucault and who was very
concerned with the exclusion of the
abnormal and the way the power does that
and then Jacques Derrida who was very
concerned with how language such as
words and language appear in pairs that
give give that hierarchical pairs in
fact that give the words meaning normal
only means something because there's
abnormal to compare it to and dairy does
wonder it as hypotheses is that one of
those words has a positive valence in
one of those words as a negative valence
and then again the confusion between
descriptive and moral understandings of
those rocky murky waters am i right in
thinking that your actual you'll have
you got PhD in maths is that right
that's right that is correct
PhD mathematics and you're now swimming
in these waters yeah it's actually
really interesting most of the people
that are mo where of the hair being the
other than Helen who's Helen pluckers
who's probably the most astute
mind on all of this is in terms of total
like wide view and clarity most of the
people working in in this that are
critical of it are coming out of things
like mathematics and science so I don't
think that I've decided to start
learning
I I don't know I think the I mean you
see certainly mathematicians well maybe
less mathematicians but certainly
scientists are if they're not on board
with it are likely to be very prone to
wanting to - I mean it's it's very
irritating to them to see these abuses
of logic and empiricism and epistemology
I was going to say so is it partly
because you guys are one of the bastions
of sort of true academia there's you
know a lot of the listeners will be
familiar with how many times someone has
said on this podcast if the subject has
the word science in it it's not a true
science or if it's got studies in it it
tends to not be a true science because
nothing physics doesn't have the word
science in it chemistry doesn't have the
way it's only a lot of slightly more
spurious topics and subject areas which
need to reaffirm their scientific nasai
ins in the title and I wouldn't know
whether it was probably I wonder whether
this is the old guard just enough that
sort of padded that elbow padded jackets
and putting the chalkboards down to like
come out and have a crack it protecting
true academia so yeah I actually do
think the more I think about it the more
I am convinced so that maybe I'm
deluding myself or I'm getting more
right I don't know but the more I think
about it the more I'm convinced that
most of what is happening regarding all
this very academic side of the culture
or the social justice and the
scholarship and all of this postmodern
stuff and all ultimately comes down to a
gigantic culture war between the
sciences and the humanities that's been
raging since like the 30s that's what's
going on it's a turf war yeah so I think
what happened was it became undeniable
that the scientists were getting much
better answers about the world then the
harder of the science has got the more
rigorous they got the better the answers
they were getting and said
this you know kind of armchair
philosophy sort of thing you used to be
able to do and you were a natural
philosopher and so on and so forth and
you could just kind of like if you look
at the advancement even in like
psychology from Freud which is all kind
of unfalsifiable and he's just sitting
back thinking about stuff and writing it
down to you know what we expect now
which is very deeply when it's done well
very deeply rigorous and experimental
and experimental control controls and
statistics and you can't just you know
well everybody wants to have sex with
their mother and then that results in
you know you can't do that anymore and
so you've had this like hardening up and
so you had the the side of scholarship
that was more of the well I want to sit
back in my armchair and talk talk about
issues he had that well let's go get our
hands dirty with the data the two sides
of it and the science just keeps
stealing ground from the other ones and
I think they're bitter about it and
they've been bitter about it for decades
and want their ground back you see it
really strongly with analytic
philosophers and moral philosophers
especially where they feel like science
is encroaching upon you know they they
were they're like the highest end of
philosophy and the science is
encroaching on their turf and they're
very hostile about it and get really
worked up but the french post modernists
for example were extraordinary Foucault
in particulars extraordinarily
pessimistic about science his whole
shtick was well you know like well I'm a
philosopher I'm a historiography and I'm
gonna tell you about the history of how
science was was wrong and science was
wrong here and then science thought it
was better and science was wrong again
and you know it's just this whole kind
of well science can't do anything right
and I actually think that's how Foucault
took off is these literary theory
departments that we're trying to do a
lot of social activism realized that
Foucault gave them a tool to point out
how science is more a long-standing
string of failures with gigantic moral
consequences than it is a rigorous and
legitimate method so it gave people a
way to criticize science without having
to do science allowing that turf
for to just flare up and like the
highest level and so who's gonna come
out and defend it
scientists yeah that's what you saw in
the 90s with what's called the science
Wars now you had like gross and Levitt
and Sokol and I can't think of all the
names up against these mostly French
postmodern philosophers and just this
really heated culture war within the
Academy wait it was wait it was raging
between them and and I think ultimately
the science side won the battle but
maybe lost the work as the theorists
went underground and have now come back
with a vengeance with seven seven arms
and eight heads and and and the
breathing fire and also stuff somebody
recently that I was talking to I can't
think of who it was so I apologize to
whoever that was said it's like a Hydra
and I think that's a really good analogy
you cut off a head and it grows to more
and it seems to be a Hydra that doesn't
know it's a Hydra which is is really
peculiar is the fluffy bunny or
something like that
so we've now you actually do have by the
way a touch of how these ideas came to
be what they are is you had these
Philosopher's well I mean to call people
like Foucault or philosophers are really
tough stretch of the word he wasn't
considered that by his contemporaries
his legacy and France isn't very good
same with Derrida but you had these
ultimately these people that were
structuralist so and became very you
know it's a very strange branch of
philosophy that then got tied in with
German idealism with what the Frankfurt
School really was coming from and then
got really pessimistic and cynical and
just started doing their strange thing
and it eventually caught on I guess as
to why but I get it let's let's take it
from we've got about 20 minutes or so
James can you try and take us through a
journey let's imagine that we're it is
it Epcot at Disneyland or whatever it
might be and we're gonna go on a little
roller coaster we're gonna sit in the
room
Sterne this is social justice from
beginning until now am I gonna sit in
there so why are we where are we going
first was the roller coaster takers
first
Hell's Kitchen New York City early
1900's or late 1800's with a guy named I
mean so the term I think originated in
the 1820s or 40s but I don't know
exactly what it referred to I haven't
gone that far back I'm not going to talk
about Marx although Marx is gonna be
very influential and I'm gonna try to
direct it to a number of streams but the
word social justice gained a lot of its
relevance actually with Baptist minister
in sketching named Walter Rauschenbusch
who invented what was called social
gospel and if you go back and read the
social gospel it looks a lot like the
social justice of today and we're gonna
leave that as a seed except that Roshan
Boucher ended up working with people in
on your side of the pond he came over to
London and got in cahoots with the
Fabian Society early on which is a
far-left organisation eventually spawned
the London School of Economics which is
a socialist School of Economics and so
on think tank now and so he came back to
Hell's Kitchen he's so social justice
started to become a thing within a
within the Baptist religion of all
things which is very conservative now
which is kind of funny so turns out
rostrum Bush was Richard Rorty who's one
of the American post modern philosophers
Rauschenbusch was his grandfather so
that's kind of like track number one
then I want to take you to Frankfurt and
by Frankfurt I actually mean Frankfurt
kind of in mostly New York City because
the Frankfurt School was mostly in New
York City because of the Nazis so they
had to leave Germany because that's when
that was going on it started in the late
20s and so not very long later most of
them relocated to New York City so
you're talking about Max Horkheimer
Theodor Adorno Herbert markussi
eventually a decade later two decades
later Jurgen Habermas Walter Benjamin
was early on allegedly Adorno's stole
most of Benjamin's ideas and so these
guys laid as we talked at the beginning
of the conversation they laid the
groundwork for this critical theory idea
and they ended up especially coming off
of Mark oosa the groundwork for what
became known as the social movement
known as a new left and the new left is
what was responsible for all of the when
you talk about the crazy politics of the
1960s and all of the riots especially
around 1968 the new left was really what
was responsible for that so these guys
vision for how society should be
organized and ultimately viewed through
critical theory in order to overthrow
the hidden oppressions and justices of
liberalism and Western civilization
became a huge like political movement on
the far left it defined the radical left
so all your radical feminists your black
power movement you know Malcolm X etc
all of that would have had in some sense
either direct or indirect ties to the
thinking of the new left and so that
kind of whole far left radical activist
morass which was actually quite violent
at the time in the 60s that you know you
got the may 1968 what was in France and
Paris you got whatever happened in the
u.s. some of the riots got pretty
intense Berkeley and so on and so that
would be kind of like the second stop on
our little roller coaster is that
philosophy there so especially like I
said Mark kusa who was extremely
influential with these these kids yeah I
actually saw an interview with him from
the 70s where he was a bit dismayed with
how people were taking up his ideas and
being uncaring kind of roughshod and
wild with them I was gonna say so that
we can we can kind of have a code you
say one of those dips takes like a PhD
level dipstick of the intensity of how
much this is becoming malignant because
you know we hear these things we've got
Malcolm X we've got you these are just
in most people's eyes the
some extreme tactics that are being used
but there just causes there's a few
people that were there I can see these
and say that shouldn't have happened so
where does this try to sort of lose its
way as well
so yeah we'll get there so I want to
actually dip back to Paris for a minute
because around that same time around
6:00 the 60s and early 70s is when you
had the post modernists really coming to
bear now the context in Europe more
broadly of course also was the collapse
of colonialism at this point so you had
the post-colonial people really starting
to speak out about how bad empire was
and the damage that that did and it's
kind of set now it became very actually
central to European new left thinking
whereas at roughly the same time in the
u.s. it started shifting toward anti
Vietnam War sentiment and so they kind
of had two different paths going on
there so the post modernists arose in
the European context of being French and
highly influenced by some of the German
idealist s-- philosophers and so they
they were at the Sorbonne that I think
the University of Paris in Paris anyway
and they all kind of work together and
study together and you have this kind of
whole little group of you know Derrida
Foucault etc they didn't always agree
sometimes they didn't like each other
sometimes they did but there was a sort
of occasionally Marxist occasionally
Leninist occasionally Maoist
occasionally not that occasionally
communists occasionally anti-communist
but very far left there is no stable
knowledge we got because the
post-colonial context we have to look at
different cultures
there's no way to compare a culture
we've been doing that that was unjust we
were saying Western cultures better so
they had to cut back from the pull back
from all that kind of thing very
culturally relative we can't really
obtain objective truth we think that the
West is so good but it made World War
two you know all this death and
destruction it came up with the Atlantic
slave trade became an interesting topic
all of these horrors that came out of
Western culture so we can't keep saying
it's
good and postmodern theory was born and
so I think postmodern theory was
actually not really it was it was an
offshoot of and not really in line with
the rest of what the so called New Left
was doing and then so where did it
really start there are already problems
here but where it really started to
become malignant was when those two
things came back together and that would
have been in the mid in late 1980s so
through the 70s and 80s for example
within feminism you would overwhelmingly
have had radical feminists and Marxist
feminists or they're called materialist
women or feminists being the ones doing
the analysis and they would say oh well
women were a commodity under patriarchy
and patriarchy and capitalism are in
cahoots and so the patriarchal
capitalist system is what needs to be
overthrown and so you can kind of see
this is a very radical mindset you had
people like Andrea Dworkin and all of
these characters Catherine MacKinnon who
were very against pornography as a form
of exploitation of violence against
women a lot of this dipped in and out of
the liberal feminist stuff but the
radicals were separate and more often
separatist and in intense and their
their their approach this of course is
also by the way all along stimulating a
backlash from the Conservatives who are
afraid that this is the end of society
and the making so you know something
boiling on the other side as a result of
this that's kind of important eventually
in the late 1980s you had a fusion of
postmodern methods into this radical
left thought and that's where I think it
really started to become malignant
that's where again we talked about
briefly before the introduction of the
intention to do identity politics
through postmodern methods was
introduced
that's where post modernism and
liberalism were simultaneously critiqued
heavily by these theorists but the
conclusion was that post-modernism was
just the problems with post-modernism
postmodern myth has most the right ideas
except that it was formulated by white
Western well-off men who could afford to
deconstruct everything
and so when you look at oppression you
can't deconstruct that experience you
can't deconstruct that injustice
hence the turn toward identity
centrality so you had that whole twist
toward let's do identity politics and
let's do it with postmodern methods if
you really wanted to stick a date stamp
on it I would tell you it was 1989 is
when that happened but really anywhere
from 1984 up through in 1994 is when
that was developing and cooking and all
of the biggest pieces and most of the
groundwork was laid and from there it's
just actually kind of concretize most of
this happening in the United States
now once the post-modernism was picked
up by these American philosophers so
like kimberlé crenshaw is a legal
scholar Judith Butler as a I guess a
philosopher or something but the queer
theorist is the best way to describe her
now as it's certainly picked up by all
these Americans that just took off I'm
not entirely sure why it took off so
heavily in the American Academy whereas
it was kind of poo pooed and France and
France where it was originated nobody in
the continent or in England was
particularly interested and it just took
off in the US and then of course our
academics exported it to yours and
especially to Australian ones who were
also very interested in these kinds of
things the first Women's Studies
department actually was in Sydney in
Australia which that would have been
more of the radical line so that's how
it started to change and what it changed
into by 2010 and anybody who's
interested will be able to read this in
great detail in the book I wrote with
Helen which is due out in May called
cynical theories by 2010 or so it had
become just the phrase that is probably
best used as it's hard to say this and
have it be understood it's known knowns
things that are known to be known things
that people just therefore accept is
being generally true so all of the
postmodern theorizing all of the
the attempts to reify certain points
around identity that went into the
identity politics turn in the late 80s
and early 90s and then the developments
that preceded in the next decade or so
everybody just started taking those
things for granted
well that's true everybody knows that we
have decades of theory saying that
that's true there's no reason to say no
that that can't be right we have so much
scholarship now all saying that that's
true and so I 2010 they just started
kind of mixing everything together and
and this sort of super intersectional
framework where solidarity and Ally ship
became kind of core ideas that had to be
paid full attention to all the time and
it started coming out of the academies
and into society then when they speak
about it now it used to be this crazy
highfalutin jargon that nobody
understood complicated sentences now
it's quite clear it's almost religious
in its quality it's if you could listen
to for example Robyn D'Angelo is a
famous whiteness scholar it sounds very
much like a woman talking to children
with her theory it's comprehensible by a
ten-year-old very straightforward very
clear very self-assured absolutely
confident in the underlying assumptions
that these systems of power are the
correct way to view the world and the
identity is at the core of systems of
power and knowledge and who can have
what in society and do what in society
so that's sort of like the broad tour of
how this all has come down largely
because it tends to eat itself also it
tends to concentrate you know and get
more and more virulent anybody who kind
of says well maybe it's a little bit not
quite that extreme is that person's
gonna get shut down big time so this is
this is slowly this is a really
interesting point that came up in my
discussion with Douglas Murray and with
other people as well which is that it
needs discussion zinc as we increasingly
sort of polarize the opinions about any
topic the room for nuance and I suppose
this loops to how to have impossible
conversation
which is your most recent book the room
for nuance and subtlety is is largely
missing and the problem is that to your
own side if you're in this quite sort of
militant discussion where you're
supposed to be as aggressive or or as
convincing as possible to your own side
nuance and subtlety
sounds like a lack of commitment to the
cause and to the other side nuance and
subtlety
sounds like a lack of conviction or a
potential weak point in your argument do
you think that's fair so yeah yeah I
think that's right and there's been a
little while ago I was giving you the
tour and I said that all along each step
along the way the new left the riots in
1968 the turn toward identity politics
etc and then more recently all the
things where it's become you know widely
disseminated I left out that this
happened mostly in where it got the
tightest hold as an education or schools
of education have basically been social
justice oriented since the 1980s which
is becoming a problem critical pedagogy
is what it's called and it's been more
or less the only approach not even the
dominant approach the only approach to
education so if it's an education I read
that for example in colleges areas the
kalos was coming from the colleges what
I read was at the universities actually
experienced it as a student-led change
where did the students get it from their
previous education which was critically
oriented because our colleges of
education have been doing critical
pedagogy since the 80s so all along
though I said that there's this
right-wing backlash brewing well guess
what the far left side of this
interprets the far right side of this as
proof that their theories are correct
that society really is corrupt and
society really is trying to protect its
vested interests in the so called status
quo and the powerful people really are
pushing back against them and they of
course are going to have your irrational
backlashes mean
while they double down because of the
exact dynamic you just said nuance can't
be allowed because it looks like a lack
of commitment or betrayal and from the
other side it looks like you know a weak
point and so both sides have actually
pulled apart from one another it's
seeing the other as as I Helen and I
wrote an article in 2017 that we titled
this dynamic existential polarization
where both sides now actually believes
if the other side gets any power
whatsoever it's an existential threat
either to the planet or to our way of
life or to our civil our civilizations
or societies or something like this and
so that's absolutely non-negotiable
nuance can't possibly exist in such a
situation it's no longer a threat to
just your side it's a threat to
everybody even the people who aren't
involved and who don't know it and
they're a threat to themselves as well
right right and so a critical theory of
course stems out of this idea that
generally the unwashed masses don't know
what's good for them that was more or
less at Antonio Graham she's underlying
idea that was what you saw a lot of the
motivation on the Frankfurt School was
that if you leave the masses to choose
things for themselves they won't choose
art and poetry they'll choose football
and beer and go into the strip club or
whatever it happens to be and so people
tend not to choose what's best for
themselves and they need some kind of
philosopher king to be able to choose
for them the post modernists in
particular Baudrillard in leotard were
particularly concerned with this so
baudrillard especially was that people
never pick art and poetry they're always
gonna pick some low culture trash if you
let them make their own choices so they
clearly don't know how to make good
decisions and everything's artificial
and everything's fake now so which is
also you can kind of see that kind of
like out gaming or that increasing sort
of caricature ISM of what's going on you
know if you were to look at something
twenty years ago and say oh you think
that that's vacuous like justjust just
wait until you see what happens when
Instagram arrives just wait into these
new items when the Kardashians get on TV
like you know we are able to outdo
ourselves even in how Halloween which is
yeah yeah
it's yeah well the left sees the the the
right way I should say I guess that the
the left that's all into this like kind
of high-minded thing that doesn't trust
the masses sees the right is choosing
against their own interests so the right
as background you know the right
conservatives all backed corporate
interests and they you know big politics
and a bunch of white men in a room and
smoking jackets or whatever the hell is
the things are right and so the average
conservative is backing something that's
against his own interests and he just
has to be informed and brought back
around to the right side of thinking and
then he wouldn't choose conservatives
anymore whereas the Conservatives are
like the Liberals are trying to do some
damn social engineering program they
call it the liberal agenda and if we do
that society's gonna collapse and you
can actually sit back for like two
seconds and look at the dynamic and
think man we're [ __ ]
how does that stop yeah yeah I mean yeah
I I think what's going on so cheers or
something no okay so to finish up James
put your money where your mouth is now
what does the next five to ten years
look like for this dynamic that's so
hard to answer because it depends on a
lot of things I do think the next
election in the US presidential election
well it's you know we do all of our
elections is going to be a a big
variable in how that goes
my perception so we'll take that off the
table for the moment because it's a big
wild card and nobody really knows what's
gonna happen and everybody's kind of
scared but nothing it doesn't look like
anything Goods coming take that off of
the table do you think that's going to
be a keystone in terms of sort of where
we go moving forward I think it's very
likely that it will be yeah it's but I
don't want to like also say this is the
election of a lifetime because then that
increases those stakes and makes
everything worse
I think one of the only or biggest
lessons of Trump is that because I think
Trump's a disaster
general but one of the biggest lessons
you can pull out of his presidency is
the most stuff still works okay even
with that in the White House so calm
down about politics whoever's the
president isn't nearly as important as
we've been thinking for the last 20 or
30 years but as far as social justice
goes right now the dynamic I just
described I have no idea the social
justice part of it I feel like is
collapsing under its own weight
but it's at the same time rapidly
institutionalizing so I anticipate that
a lot more organizations companies legal
entities whatever they happen to be are
going to go loke as it as it were and
that woke miss is going to end up
hamstringing them and so we'll see a lot
of important institutions and less
important institutions that see a lot of
damage as the thing starts to collapse
under its own weight which is I think
what's happening by so it's like weights
is it's not just some of the inherent
ridiculousness and self-contradictory
nassif the situation implode yes yes and
it's for example I saw the other day
article that I read this is maybe two
weeks ago about the problem of settlers
of color and so what is a settler of
color this is a black person say in
North America who for whatever reason
they ended up there you know they stole
indigenous land also so this is
basically a turf war for victimhood
status between black and indigenous as
kind of the maximum racial victimhood
status and it's a clear bid that the
indigenous are going to try to throw the
black people under the bus by saying
that their settlers of color so the
infighting alone is going to really
hobble what they're able to do I also
see that there is - there are two things
happening at once one is good and one is
bad in response to all this a lot of
people on both of those two things are
waking up to what's going on social
justice has shown its hand a lot of
people have become very interested in
the problem and are studying it like I
have like Helen has
and that's going to increase
tremendously and people are going to
understand what it is and when they
understand what it is they will do what
they can to reject it the bad side of
that is going to be the backlash side
which is going to be a turn again toward
making traditional gender roles cool
maybe a turn toward racism certainly a
lot less sensitivity than we actually
should have toward issues of identity
disability wholesale rejection like that
sure and there's these new movements
it's like I guess there was like the
Trump people and now those people are
all like Kooks or something now like
they're not hardcore enough like Trump
and his family or sellout liberals or
something now from the far far far or
extra alt double right or whatever they
have a name frogs or something groupers
they call them so it's like is that what
we're looking at we're over the next
year I doubt it I don't think they're
gonna have a whole lot of steam behind
them they're a thing at the moment but
probably not much of one but it's like
the alt-right aspect is going to still
continue to swell you couldn't give them
a better recruiting ground than having
all this crazy stuff happening like with
presidential nominees and things like
that on the other hand there is also a
this is very good an enormous growth in
the interest in liberalism and the
underpinnings of how liberal societies
should work and why those principles
should be in place and how to defend
them tremendous amount of interest and
I'm seeing that from people on the left
I'm seeing it from people who identify
as centrist and people on the right so
and those people will
despite retaining tremendous
disagreements politically will be able
to rise up and say you know what a
liberal on the right and a liberal on
the left have more in common than these
fools on the extreme and so they will
they will probably start to pick in
elections less predictably and more well
predictable toward whoever's being the
most liberal for example you see this
kind of broad coalition I don't think
it's going to work out but broad
coalition for candidates like Andrew
yang who are being in the u.s. right now
who are being very
traditionally liberal weather left or
right doesn't actually matter I think
you would see you see a lot of
conservative supporting him despite many
of his policies or being open to his
Paula is his ideas despite his policies
whereas normally you would just sit
would be you know Democrat trying to get
you know position terrible you're not
seeing that so you're starting to see
this broader open-minded thing where
people and I think it would be reflected
as well if you had a very centrist
Republican who's trying to push back
against whatever is going on right now
with the far-right politics it's the
populism that's dominating I think you'd
see a lot of left-wing support coming
out for central center left support
coming out for that so I see this huge
rebirth like almost a Renaissance of
liberalism and that's the place that I'm
trying to stick myself into is to
encourage that to expose the thing that
we're looking at the social justice
malignant social justice thing and try
to resurrect you know proper liberal
principles including liberal social
justice principles like you said earlier
are actually really good and it's almost
everybody short of a small fringe off on
the right agree with them one of the
things I've thought of as you've got
towards the end of this discussion we've
been talking about sort of this I it
analogize to a virus and we're talking
about when did it become malignant and
things like that I've got it in my head
thinking about how a vaccination works
the vaccination gives you a very small
dose of a potentially lethal virus and
then you realize your system realizes
[ __ ] I'm pretty vulnerable to this I
need to do something and I wonder I
wonder how much this particular social
justice movement is going to be a
vaccination against something else which
could have or may arise in the
not-too-distant future for which we will
need to be able to marshal an
appropriate response and that this
situation that we have encountered
recently will have been a canary in the
coal mine to go oh you didn't you didn't
know that this was a problem let me tell
you like this is this is this really is
a problem in you you've got to be ready
for it but we didn't get the smooth
walking slick dist a future dystopian
Overlord from like some James Bond film
we didn't get him
we got like Native Americans versus like
black settler like who's got them who is
the most underprivileged in this
situation like fat studies that's who we
got yeah we can get the owner of some
huge billion-dollar media conglomerate
who's actually really really nefarious
with it we got like people with blue
head are unhappy that they didn't get
enough hugs as a kid I don't wonder I
wonder whether or not that that will
actually end up being in the long term
whether that will end up serving as well
because it will prepare us for what's to
come it's possible I think it's going to
be really important that we understand I
think that it's not centralized like the
like the dangerous guy with the big
money and all of that but critical
theory is a real it's again like we
talked about it's like it's like an
industrial-grade solvent and so learning
how to deal with that as a society is
going to be really really important and
so perhaps it's as you're suggesting
best that it's in the hands of these
self-defeating oddballs in grievance
mongers rather than you know the next
Hitler
who's going to come out and know how to
wield those tools to much worse end it's
certainly a possibility I do think
though that understanding that the
potential for critical theory to be
something that can literally dissolve a
liberal or Western society or any
society really because it can latch on
and change itself to fit anything is of
paramount importance right now and so
administering kind of like the the
critical theory jab and and giving
people that vaccine I think is super
important at the moment well I'm excited
I'm looking forward to the book to come
out with with hella next year thank you
so much for today James where should
should listen his head if they want to
keep in touch do you find out mom I am
probably pathologically active on
Twitter so that's the best place to look
for me and reach out to me I'm at
conceptual James on Twitter there should
be some big things coming in the next
few months so if those pan out people
should be getting excited and check and
check me out and see what's going on so
that's the place to look for now I'm
looking forward to it James thank you so
much to the listeners at home you know
what to do if you've enjoyed this
episode go and follow James check out
how to have impossible conversations and
don't wait for his book with Helen which
will be coming out early next year like
share subscribe all that good stuff you
know what to do
but for now thank you James thank you
[Music]
you